a quick warning if you are good at
empathizing with other people this
week's guest video may make you feel
short of breath seriously without out of
the way let me introduce you to Curtis
berry filming from inside his homemade
airtight bio dome Curtis good luck just
over 8 hours ago I sealed myself inside
of this cube it is 10 feet by 10 feet by
10 feet
holds roughly 30,000 litres there I want
to try to make this as short and sweet
as I can because with every breath that
I take I am exhaling carbon dioxide and
it is toxic at high enough levels right
now it's a six thousand three hundred
and seventy parts per million but to
explain what that really means I'm gonna
have to step back a second okay I built
this airtight plant filled bio dome for
a series of videos on my channel about
how we interact with the air we breathe
I have a bunch of safety equipment
including oxygen and carbon dioxide
sensors and other gases and backups and
blood monitors and a paramedic on site
do not try this at home it is just don't
travel I want to step back sixty years
ago to when carbon dioxide levels in our
atmosphere were around 300 parts per
million modern day because of
industrialization and burning fossil
fuels those levels are now around 400
parts per million in natural landscapes
and in urban environments it's more like
500 parts per million but the thing is
we spend most of our time indoors and
that's often in poorly ventilated spaces
where the carbon dioxide levels can
reach a thousand parts per million and
what's important here is that
researchers have gone out and tested the
higher order decision-making abilities
of office employees at different levels
of carbon dioxide's and they found that
at 1,000 parts per million there is a
15% decrease in cognitive function
that's a big deal because we spend a lot
of our time in those sorts of
environments for example researchers
went to schools in Texas Idaho
Washington and they found that in over
50% of those classrooms the carbon
dioxide levels went above 1,000 parts
per million in those same studies they
found that when levels reached 1,400
there was a 50% decrease in cognitive
function and by 2000 there are all sorts
of side effects which I am feeling a lot
of including nausea loss of attention I
have to read I have to read them
some people report headaches sleepiness
poor concentration loss of attention
eating increased heart rate and slight
nausea but still these levels aren't
uncommon carbon dioxide levels in
bedrooms and cars frequently reach 4,000
parts per million and those are places
that we spend a lot of our time in we
used to use carbon dioxide as an
indicator for when air was stale but
it's actually probably the most
important part of what makes air stale
its 6,500 parts per million in here
right now and the air feels thick it is
clouding my brain it is making me do way
more takes in this video than I would
have hoped when we reached 10,000 parts
per million you're not supposed to work
an eight-hour day in an environment like
that because it's probably bad for your
long-term health you wouldn't want to be
riding a motorcycle with that much
carbon dioxide around you but research
shows that it's not uncommon for
motorcycle helmets to have carbon
dioxide levels that are that high and I
cannot imagine being impaired at this
level and riding a motorcycle let alone
at 10,000 parts per million still we
have to go up quite a bit we have to go
all the way up to 30,000 before the
levels become extremely dangerous and
potentially deadly now I have some bad
news and I have some good news the bad
news is that carbon dioxide levels are
going to go up there might even reach
695 parts per million by the end of the
century
and that means that globally we could
end up with something like a 10% or a
16% decrease in our cognitive function
as a species and that's a big deal the
good news is that we have the ability
right now to change the environments
that we live in both in terms of the
overall climate and in terms of the
stale air spaces that we inhabit so you
can go out and open a window in your
office I don't have that luxury but you
can you can get some plants in your
house you can make sure that your HVAC
your air ventilation systems are
up-to-date and functioning and then you
can use that cognitive surplus you can
use that bonus to your thinking
abilities to try and find solutions for
climate change and how you can make a
difference Tom thank you so much for
having me I'm gonna lie down and stop
talking Thank You Curtis go subscribe to
his channel you can start with this
series from inside his bio dome or if
that is a bit much right now
I also recommend his one take video on
the entire history of the universe next
week is the final guest video and it's
all about neuroscience